hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play the gray
eagle okay we got no time to waste let's
get the lights up and oh look at this we
found a slide and even though the lights
are not behaving the way they should we
are still standing in professional
darkness so it doesn't matter let's just
carry on with our lives
chunky look at that dog Wow ah boomers
boomers you're not a pooper are you
you're not a pooper where the hell did
you come from
geez don't start that earlier with me
you're a pooper - yeah friggin poopy
poof you son of a [ __ ] I hope you go
rot in hell
boop boop Kurt Junkers there we go
alright the door is open nobody is gonna
be a douche around here at least not for
the next few minutes your chunker's
would that do oh who cares let's just
ascend into the darkness kind of like
the opposite of the original amnesia Hey
look at the particles they rotate okay
they don't rotate them alright did you
watch out for that monster behind you
I'm really sorry that I summoned him
into your house enough as soon as it
gets dark if it's not dark already I'm
really sorry but Sean ah ha ha ha ha ha
ha that's been happening the whole game
like every time I step over a shovel it
just like goes blue and this one finally
decided to launch me into the ground my
god I don't think I could recreate that
if I tried but you thought monster got
you though out perfect timing
ok so anyway I'm have shenanigans in
this department huh hey I'm just cute
just curious
nope nope Oh what oh no oh what you're
gonna go all over the place but no oh oh
really you're gonna go up here well
let's see if we can yep yep throw me
into the ground see couldn't recreate it
if
I tried in no way could I recreate that
holy hell that's unbelievable I am the
game breaking master okay stop now that
is some other shade of horrifying green
we are going to continue forward are we
out of this nightmare
No do we have more absolutely we do huh
that's weird ever seen something like
that before okay
is this a bathroom is that's always a
bathroom that's the flickering light in
the bathroom oh so cool it's disgusting
but that's cool all right
key someone had a rough time in that
stall until you would room protect my
broom okay oh you're right in there
you're right okay have fun
what's down here dog oh I didn't want to
know ah why did I ask
okay so keen this is boarded up no no
let's not go that way first how about we
try this Curt chunk no really
I'm actually surprised to something
didn't happen to this bathroom here ha
ha ha well I miss some hey hey did I
miss some here I miss some there some
okay just checking
don't want to make sure I miss any
scares area continuing forward something
let's see up down let's go down first
for some stupid what though well let's
not go down let's not go that way let's
go up first
oh boy little se by a wide ha ha ha ha
ha Wow it was more surprising cuz I'd
never seen anything like that coming at
me so ya know all right so we got a
bunch of floors here
gone in the second yeah cuz second is
always best new is always best that's
the number one rule new is always better
new faces new food wait a minute whoa oh
holy backtracking Batman whoa holy bad
framerate Batman get us out ere ha ha ha
ha
we went back to that area that we were
before how intriguing
well then why did I take the elevator if
there were stairs here I mean really I
mean really kerthump yes I can't go in
there I guess I gotta go in the second
floor poop skittles damn it turn it down
gosh darn it okay so ho Cisco bad frame
rate for some reason there's like
something in this level that causes a
terrible drop in framerate randomly I
remember it from before even my
super-powered gerbil wheel cannot
withstand the power Oh you giant frickin
lair yeah I have a journal note no
mementos I guess I don't deserve a clue
until I solved the puzzle what was Donny
that I missed before that was locked
ooh second floor kitchen okay cool all
right
Oh No okay never mind then I got excited
over nothing
so now I need to find the kitchen eh
whoo okay young all right hahahahaha
okay where was the kitchen was it in
here no where was the kitchen
I don't recall please tell me this might
be something here that I could use nope
I've got next to no oil because this
whole son of a [ __ ] stupid game
wouldn't even come close to give me what
I needed a kitchen catching perfect ooh
what the that's a strange shadow oh
that's nice
oh that's a big ass spider my big ass
spider I mean that's a big ass spider
great nothing I silly jokes aside
there's blood dripping from the ceiling
this is a lovely lovely lovely place
hello hello nothing nothing nothing
nothing nothing okay pig that has been
thoroughly diced and sliced this for
some reason morphine in the kitchen all
right okay all right this is looking
good I like God
gosh you [ __ ] Speier God should have
murdered you when I had the chance
ah yes Tobin's son oh I don't even see
where you are I don't even wanna know
screw you everything you care about
spider [ __ ]
Shh weiter son of ugh I see you who
couldn't see you with an ass that big
they could see you from the moon
whatever
picked up old key to what first floor
huh who said that who said that who did
that who said that what's going on
whitey
I'll be out I'm out you beautiful
creature you what is that music I've
never heard that music before something
going on I don't like it something's
happening I don't want no part of it
okay aah aah
Xander hey son of a [ __ ] you son of a
[ __ ] Alex I'm gonna oh yeah come after
me bro oh what's that I'm long gone from
there oh you so seriously that music is
disturbing and I've never heard it
before in my life
hey were you the guy that was crouched
in that room with the shadow up on the
wall didn't just mean you finally
decided to come out of hiding
yeah try you son of a [ __ ] stay down
there and die with the rest of them I'm
going in the first floor Kurt chunk
O'Doyle rules I read the comics as
someone said when I said O'Doyle rules
that someone thought I said Goyle rules
I've no idea what the hell that is but
you're dumb and you should feel bad for
not getting the O'Doyle rules reference
who the hell is going boy el rules nah
maybe I'm dumb I'm probably I knew
you'll reach this place to this place
yes it's me again your savior open the
door get on the floor everybody do the
dinosaur you asked what kind of nonsense
is going on head honestly I don't know
what's there are however oh this is your
choice to go forward into the unknown or
run away well is this
run away choice oh let's go oh oh oh hi
Alexander well let's see here
whoa what the oh it's one of these
mechanics
I hate these mechanics oh this looks
good oh yeah oh yeah my lantern broke
good good justification for that
happening and somehow I'm back in modern
times or was I ever in modern times do I
know what any of this is do I know why
any of this is oh sorry really watch out
for that monster behind you it's getting
dark so sorry what uh-oh nike's No ah ah
yah oh you know I was all a dream
apparently oh boy all a dream man oh
whatever
alright what I'm gonna do I'm gonna get
out of here I'm gonna get back into it
see if I can't load up so I can see the
under ending real quick cuz I still got
time anyway this has been a really great
custom story I've really really enjoyed
it thoroughly
come on custom story ray go look game um
that's weird
oh it's different okay that's right okay
um times now this one how far back is
this there's this right at the end you
tell me you tell me mr. monster man
don't don't tell ah okay you're gonna
have to find someone else to uh do all
that because I'm not backtracking I'm
sorry I'm not dedicated enough for that
but anyway this was a great custom story
um if you played it yourself I would
highly recommend it it was in fantastic
loved it try the other ending for
yourself that way you can see what
happened in the other end
I don't have to do all that so thank you
all so much for watching click the in
the taste of more videos that I've done
got a suggestion for the next custom
story write in the comments below thanks
again and as always I will see you in
the next video
Wow
ah
Oh
love
ah that was scary